[Música]
compartir mi aprendizaje y mi
aprendizaje a partir de trabajar con
emprendedores con empresarios que muchos
están acá y que me han enseñado quizá
que siete cositas que me han enseñado y
son empresarios y emprendedores que
están cambiando duro todo el tiempo por
transformar esta industria por
evolucionar y ellos de verdad les quiero
dedicar este test porque son los que me
inspiran todo el tiempo y por los que
siento que vale la pena seguir
apostándole a este sector de la economía
creativa y de la de los contenidos y el
primer aprendizaje es nomás fatalismo
nosotros hemos aprendido a convivir todo
el tiempo con una idea que los medios
tradicionales se van a acabar
que se van a desaparecer y que las
nuevas plataformas van a ocupar ese
espacio de los medios tradicionales
escuchamos también todo el tiempo que
los jóvenes no van a ver más televisión
que las marcas tampoco van a seguir
pautando con nosotros y que ha venido
pasando los medios tradicionales
seguimos acá estamos conviviendo con las
nuevas plataformas los jóvenes siguen
viendo televisión y las marcas siguen
pactando y siguen creyendo en el poder y
en el valor de lo que creamos entonces
esto no es un tema de crisis esto es un
tema de cambio esto es un tema de
evolución y hay una empresa bogotana que
hoy me acompaña y que hoy está acá que
se llama dirty kids in es una empresa
que lleva 8 años en el mercado genera 90
empleos permanentes y de que viven su
modelo de negocio claramente está basado
en contenidos digitales en monetizar sus
audiencias y cuando yo converso con
ellos con felipe
y con iván me han dicho muchas veces
miren es que si los creadores de
contenidos en alta escala creen que van
a poder crear empresas o creen que van a
poder generar empleo de lo que les
generan los nuevos jugadores pues están
muy equivocados o sea no van a poder
generar empleo ni generar riqueza con lo
que con lo que lleguen a montar en
facebook con lo que lleguen a montar en
youtube eso se lo dejo ahí hago este así
mil eso se lo dejo a mi hija de 15 años
que todo el tiempo está montando vídeos
y que seguramente si les llega un cheque
de mil dólares en una semana pues va a
ser muy feliz pero los grandes creadores
de contenidos no resulta inviable vivir
de esto y ellos hoy en día están
produciendo contenidos para marcas están
produciendo series y yo les quiero
mostrar este este negocio de ellos y
este ejemplo de esta serie que ellos
acaban de producir para bancolombia
qué sucede cuando el poder de inspirar
muy fuerte hacer 50
[Música]
frutas
y las medias verdades han generado una
mala prensa para el aceite de palma
el sector financiero tradicionalmente ha
sido muy masculino no podemos cambiar lo
que los años que hiciste
hemos ido desarrollando dos estilos son
los esquemas de unas formas de vida que
demandan el uso del recurso de la tierra
[Música]
es igual
el cual se encuentra quien logra
comprobar parte del salto cualitativo
un saludo es total
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero también tenemos que hacer todos
nuestra parte para entender la velocidad
y adaptarnos y al enviarnos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y mucho más nos entusiasma creo que mira
te morís yo hago los amigos de una
generación sorprendente y una gran
experiencia para el futuro de la
humanidad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en castellano
[Música]
bueno y después de mostrarles un ejemplo
de algo que es producido totalmente por
una empresa como les decía bogotana el
otro aprendizaje es que debemos adoptar
la tecnología antes de que ella nos
adopte a nosotros claramente los
empresarios yo me da cuenta que los
empresarios y los emprendedores han
venido entendiendo que no se trata
solamente de probar que tenemos
audiencias sino que lo realmente
importante en ese momento es tener
audiencias que se puedan medir de manera
precisa que se puedan cambiar que se
puedan manejar y si nosotros los que
estamos aquí reunidos no empezamos a
crear esa data porque hemos venido
escuchando todo el tiempo que el mundo
se mueve alrededor de la data pero si
nosotros no empezamos a crear esas
audiencias si nosotros no empezamos a
medir estas audiencias y aprovechar la
tecnología para
para digamos aprender de este contenido
de lo que ellos nos están diciendo de lo
que ésta data nos está arrojando pues
esto es algo que difícilmente nos va a
lograr llegar a poder evolucionar
el segundo aprendizaje es que los seres
humanos no solamente estamos hechos de
carne y hueso o sea los seres humanos
somos historia somos lo que contamos
somos cómo lo contamos y desde y si
nosotros los que generamos estos
contenidos y contamos estas historias
seguimos narrando una historia fatalista
de nuestra industria audiovisual eso es
lo que nuestras audiencias van a empezar
a compartir y ustedes que son los que
crean esos contenidos saben del poder
que generan los mensajes que estamos
enviando porque claramente el contenido
ustedes saben que logra derribar
barreras logra crear identidades logra
transformar realidades entonces el
aprendizaje o el mensaje que yo les
quiero dejar en este momento es si
nosotros estamos siendo felices con la
historia que estamos contando de nuestra
industria audiovisual
que ustedes están contando en nuestra
el tercer el cuarto mensaje en la
personalización del contenido desde
pequeños
nosotros hemos sabido adaptar nuestros
contenidos o sea desde desde muy
pequeños nosotros los mensajes sabemos a
quién se los dirigimos y cómo se los
dirigimos
o sea comenzamos pequeños no era lo
mismo lo que le decíamos a nuestra mamá
a nuestro abuelo oa nuestro amigo o sea
nosotros sabíamos adaptar el mensaje de
acuerdo al interlocutor y hoy en día
también nosotros sabemos adaptar los
mensajes dependiendo en las pantallas en
las que nos estemos moviendo o sea no es
lo mismo lo que nosotros
el mensaje lo que nosotros ponemos en
facebook que lo que ponemos en whatsapp
hoy en día el contenido se está
volviendo un lenguaje y hoy en día son
muchos más los lenguajes que estamos
aprendiendo a manejar que casi nuestro
mismo idioma natal entonces las nuevas
plataformas nos han llevado a
personalizar los contenidos
es algo digamos muy importante porque no
es lo mismo cuando pasamos o cuando
creemos que un contenido que pasamos por
un canal de tradicional y lo llevamos a
la web ya estamos creando contenidos
digitales no es eso esto esto no lo es y
eso muchas veces es lo que nos está
pasando y está ahí cuando de verdad
debemos tener mucho cuidado en cómo
tratamos el lenguaje en cómo aprendemos
a conocer ese lenguaje cómo nos volvemos
casi como los políglotas y cómo
aprendemos a tratar con mucho cuidado
los formatos y ahí es cuando de verdad
podemos decir que se generan unas
verdaderas evoluciones en esta industria
y acá hubo otro caso que tengo para
comentarles es una empresa colombiana
también de bogotá que se llama trineo
ellos tienen una serie web animada que
se llama vida pública esta serie no ha
pasado por ningún canal de televisión
y hoy en día tiene más de 3 millones de
seguidores ellos han empezado a crear o
han creado un universo transmedia han
creado eso que desea paula esa conexión
con sus audiencias y ha empezado a
hacerlas sentir a las audiencias parte
de ese universo que ellos han creado a
comunicarse con sus audiencias ya no
solamente tienen esta serie de webs
también tienen un cómic también tienen
un videojuego o sea han generado todo y
por qué porque han sabido cuidar muy
bien los formatos y cuidar el lenguaje
por donde se comunican con sus
audiencias
ya no existe una gran hoguera y me voy a
ir como al tiempo de las cavernas hace
muchos muchos miles de años ustedes
saben que todas las historias se
contaban alrededor de una hoguera las
tribus se sentaban alrededor de una
hoguera y alrededor de una hoguera era
que contaban lo que había pasado en el
día planeaban la casa del otro día
muchas veces hasta también se generaban
chismes en rededor de esta hoguera pero
ahí lo más importante era el contenido y
lo que sigue siendo importante eran las
historias pero hoy en día ustedes saben
que ya no tenemos una gran hoguera sino
que tenemos múltiples hogueras
pequeñitas y tenemos múltiples múltiples
plataformas y en todas estas plataformas
se están contando contenidos mucho más
especializados contenidos mucho más
particulares para audiencias mucho más
pequeñas y aquí es cuando otra vez
vuelve el reto de cómo utiliza
las nuevas herramientas tecnológicas
para que todos estos contenidos mucho
más especializados y particulares los
juntamos y creamos unos universos mucho
más coherentes y creamos unas narrativas
totales y un caso de esas narrativas
totales es esta serie que fue producida
por movistar que se llama la peste y que
una empresa que se llama el cañonazo
donde está en españa pero donde trabajan
muchos no solamente no solamente
trabajan diseñadores no solamente
trabajan o sea esta empresa tiene un
modelo de negocio en donde lo que busca
es que su talento humano sea divergente
busca juntarlos de todos los sectores y
crearon este caso que es uno es una
narrativa que a partir de una misma
historia crearon ocho historias
distintas para públicos diferentes pero
que todas se desprenden de un solo
universo
bienvenidos a las
sí
[Música]
y en relación a la temática del
espectador poder elegir sus
y que se sentía tan ligero el viaje un
mapa y una conexión mente mente del alma
de sevilla funciona como contenedor de
todos los elementos que se introduzcan o
se complementan y que sobre visibles de
40 hacia la serie
[Música]
un sitio colaborativo que compensar toda
la información derivada de la gente en
la ficción y en la realidad
historia biografías
en teoría se convierten a youtube pero
siglos para contarnos la vida
[Música]
él confesó el bienestar tanto o será el
profesor de sus propios personajes ya
cubren más días
en formato podcast te escucharán
secretos no deseados
sería presentado por dos frikis de los
efectos inspecciones que recorren platos
y salas de producción para reconstruir
el proceso
para una serie de recetas del siglo 16
traídas han sido vendidos y llegamos a
puerto donde se puede acceder a un
experto
de datos y referencias de tono
[Música]
este mes
se propaga más allá de lo digital las
personas invisibles de sevilla se
integran con señalizaciones
de las calles de la ciudad y comentar a
estos sus cambios físicos con
referencias históricas anécdotas del
rodaje
y leyendas de la vida contados a través
de textos imágenes audios y videos
independientemente del consumo de la
serie los contenidos cobran vida propia
a través de una estrategia de
distribución en medios propios y ganados
un trabajo para la demanda un equipo
multidisciplinar contacta con
comunidades comentarios
[Música]
interactivos y cierre sólo las webs
según
todos los dispositivos esta estrategia
la tracción ya expande la fricción
promocionada a seguir y la abre a la
participación del espectador una
experiencia narrativa
a la altura de las grandes propuestas
globales los invitamos al largo paseo
por sevilla
y el otro aprendizaje ya estoy
terminando es que unidos somos más
fuertes yo creo que nosotros debemos
tratar de no hablar de la competencia en
ese momento o sea en ese momento todos
somos competencia cualquiera que logre
captar la atención de una audiencia en
nuestra competencia yo creo que en este
momento y la invitación que hago es que
en la medida en que nosotros nos unamos
y podamos de verdad no pensar nos como
sectores aislados sino como un solo
sector en la medida en que podamos ser
mucho más divergentes en la medida en
que todos los que estemos aquí podamos
crear un pool de contenidos propios de
contenidos reales de contenidos nuestros
medibles cuantificables
o sea seguramente vamos a llevarle la
delantera a estos nuevos competidores
que tenemos
todos estos aprendizajes no sirven si no
se materializan o sea todo lo que ha
venido hemos venido haciendo en todas
estas charlas si no se materializan no
sirven la verdadera innovación sucede
cuando de verdad les aprendemos cuando
nos quitamos los egos cuando no somos
los que más sabemos y cuando aquí no
estamos los mejores aquí todos estamos
aprendiendo de todos y la verdadera
innovación pasa en ese momento en un
momento de co-creación en un momento de
colaboración cuando creamos
oportunidades que son digamos casi que
uno no se alcanza a imaginar que se
pueden crear y el último mensaje ya para
terminar esto es que en realidad
nosotros cambiamos o morimos
construyendo esa historia y esa
narrativa que todos nosotros hemos
venido construyendo y es que la
industria de contenidos de nuestro país
está en crisis
o nos transformamos esa misma historia o
vamos a morir en ello entonces cuando
nos pregunten cómo está la industria de
contenidos de colombia está en el mejor
momento porque está en el momento de
crear contenidos está en el momento de
reinventarse y está en el momento de que
cada uno de ustedes pueden hacer
historia eso es mi mensaje y lo que les
quiero dejar de cierre gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]